on est à j moins 7 du scrutin et il y a
d'ores et déjà plus d'américains qui ont
choisi de voter par anticipation ou par
courrier que sur l'ensemble de
l'élection de 2016 à ce rythme là selon
certaines études le scrutin pourrait
rassembler 150 millions d'électeurs ce
qui constituerait un record depuis 1908
même total trump lui-même s'est déjà
rendu aux urnes c'était temps en floride
il s'y est rendu en personne et non pas
par courrier parce qu'on sait que c'est
un dispositif sur lequel il a émis de
sérieux doutes en raison de la nouvelle
quantités massives et sans précédent de
bulletins de vote non sollicités qui
seront envoyées aux électeurs ou
ailleurs
cette année le résultat des élections du
3 novembre pourrait ne jamais être
déterminé avec exactitude ce que
certains souhaitent encore un désastre
électoral hier arrêter la folie
électorale certains états sont habitués
à ce système de vote par correspondance
mais ce n'est pas vraiment le cas pour
les états de l'est des états unis dont
certains sont des battleground state des
états clés ou peut basculer l'élection
dans ces états là le processus est
beaucoup moins bien rodée donc certains
craignent un engorgement des services
postaux ou encore un taux de rejet
important des bulletins envoyés par
courrier parce que par exemple il manque
une signature quand on sait que lors de
l'élection de 2016 certains états
s'était joué à moins de cent mille voix
d'écart il ya effectivement de quoi être
inquiet ce qui est sûr c'est que la
soirée électorale devrait être plus
confuse qu'à l'accoutumée à moins d'un
raz-de-marée pour l'un ou l'autre des
deux candidats
le suspense devrait s'étaler sur
plusieurs jours et alors le comportement
de joe biden et de donald trump sera
décisif si l'un ou l'autre venait à
revendiquer ou contester des résultats
qui ne sont pas encore définitifs alors
cela pour ajouter le trouble sur l'issue
du scrutin
selon un sondage réalisée par l'ipsos
pour reuters quatre électeurs américains
sur dix qu'ils soient pro trump ou
providers indiquent qu'ils n'accepteront
pas la défaite de leur candidat
22% des supporters pro by dane et 16%
des supporters pro trump indiquent même
qu'ils se rendront dans la rue pour
manifester
si le résultat n'est pas celui qu'ils
espèrent non je ne suis pas inquiet
notre constitution nous protège de
nombreuses choses
et l'une d'entre elles est un coup
d'état bien le fait que donald trump ne
voudrais pas quitter la maison blanche
j'espère le voir partir le 20 janvier
cela ne me préoccupe pas je ne suis pas
inquiet l'une des choses merveilleuses
aux états unis c'est que nous pouvons
aller manifester dans la rue si on le
souhaite mais cela ne me dérange pas
qu'ils disent qu'ils iront manifester si
vous me dites que quatre électeurs sur
dix n'accepterons pas le résultat
cela correspond en fait à la base
électorale de donald trump
ces personnes sont et seront toujours
derrière lui
peut-être qu'il ne l'accepterons pas
mais le résultat de l'élection sera
acceptée par la majorité des gens
ce qui m'inquiète le plus ce sont des
supporters de donald trump qui sont
constitués en milice armée et qui pense
que la réponse à beaucoup de leurs
problèmes et aux choses avec lesquelles
ils ne sont pas d'accord est une réponse
violente
cette confusion autour de l' annonce des
résultats est en tout cas redoutée par
les autorités qui ont déployé des forces
de l'ordre en nombre pour encadrer cette
élection dans un pays où les divergences
politiques se sont exprimés dans la rue
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois